jill keeps insisting on buying real ones
and i'm like what are you doing i love
real world real plants real plants
i'm going to disagree they look exactly
like like we have some we are not going
to give you the oxygen that you you need
and they smell bad but there's enough
there's enough oxygen we got a plant in
our house that i've had since
that first house
and
it's lived that long and it's even
sprouted new things yeah yeah i love my
i love my plants
it's like you're very excited to start
to do fun things like bloom
yeah well jill does too she she keeps
she keeps you know she keeps the plants
alive mm-hmm uh i can't keep a plant
alive i
why plants are [ __ ] [ __ ] man
they're [ __ ] waiting
they're [ __ ] [ __ ] not all of them
plants are [ __ ] [ __ ] like they
come okay so
you can have you can have like outside
there's a sidewalk right and through the
sidewalk you it will literally pan
plants will [ __ ] grow out of the
sidewalk that's right and yet i can have
a plant in my house right next to the
window that i water every day very
delicately and i put it in it doesn't
want to be in a pot
it wants to be under the sidewalk
smashing through the sidewalk can't hold
it down so like what's what's the
i don't i don't understand i really
don't i'm like i can give a walk i can
give a plant water and sunshine and all
the things that it says that it needs
probably giving it to you and it's still
it's like
i don't wanna i don't want to i don't
know too much
it's too much i'm wilting you know or
like well if it's wilting it's not
enough water you're really not just
you're not you're not paying attention
to it and listening to what it needs my
plants are all fine
i don't [ __ ] understand it maybe it's
because i i'm just like you're not a
plant
huh maybe it's because you're not a
player you're focused on watering
yourself you're not paying attention to
what else needs to be watered in your
house
sorry jill
[Laughter]
fake plants are where it's at yeah
you're above nature a man hates plants
my man hates plants no i just don't
understand it's real [ __ ] [ __ ]
they're
so finicky why are they so finicky how
do they survive in nature like do you
feel the same about grass
would you prefer an astroturf yard to a
grass yard no no no i'm not talking
about plants
i'm talking about indoor plants
indoor plants yeah they're [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah
plants that are planted outside outdoor
plants are fine
loves outdoor plants i like indoor
plants too they just don't [ __ ] like
themselves
they [ __ ] commit suicide every time i
have one they they they're like have you
tried a succulent something that doesn't
eat a lot of water doesn't really need a
lot of energy
everything like a little cacti i can't
keep a plant alive jill's good at it i
can't keep a plant alive i've tried and
they just they do
do you yell at them
because they can feel like i break them
after they don't do what i tell them to
do after their way out
[Music]
welcome to the podcast everybody here we
are coming in hot with glenn's take on
plants and how they're [ __ ] indoor
plants plants is [ __ ] i think it is
[ __ ] also
[Laughter]
let's start with the elephant
[Laughter]
yeah and it's disfiguring but i was just
going to come and show up and you know
be my best i want to talk about it oh my
god
because
i'm a clean person
it's that bad
that's pretty that's the elephant in the
room i don't understand st styes i do
actually sorry i do understand styles
which is gross and i'm clean
but
it is not
a coincidence that we both got styes in
our house at the same exact time you did
wake up a few days later with the style
yours is not as problematic
butterflies
no and also they're not contagious
smash eyes together we don't they're not
contagious
we smash them
and it just happened at the same time it
happens at the same time it's impossible
there's something there's something
about the air in our house here we go
she refuses to believe that it's too dry
i like a purifier we live in southern
california why would dry air does dry
air cause style no have you did you go
on webmd no
yes caused by bacteria
so it says that if if you get that
bacteria on like a pillowcase you could
technically spread it to somebody else
but
it's very unlikely any optimal i'll just
say i've talked to you and i've talked
about a few of them yeah because i've
had stuff excuse me what did you call
them ophthalmologist
nice
i heard about you
i heard ophthalmologists
it doesn't matter but it is it's
fascinating that we both have styes at
the same exact time i don't know we even
look we i have i get a style maybe once
every three years i'm so obsessed with
not getting a stye that i've got the
eyelid i i use the makeup cleanser
makeup cleanser makeup remover yeah then
i wash my face and then i i clean the
eyelid with that little yeah yeah they
have that stuff yeah you know you can
also you what helps with the sty is also
colloidal silver colloidal silver drops
put them right in your eye boom stygon
anytime i feel a sky coming colloidal
silver drops what if it's not so bad
that your eye is as the size of the pee
and the other eye is normalized yeah
that's it's too late now the elephant
has been finished you might lose the eye
at this point
i know i'm willing to take it out
because it's been like a week and a half
oh really yeah a week and a half starts
going anywhere a long time that's the
biggest
that's one of the biggest
and i didn't know whether
to mention it or not and i didn't want
it why is one of your eyes half the size
it's like quatto it's like it's gonna
start talking it's gonna it has its own
brain for the site
that's okay we were talking thanks for
having me everybody oh that's bad
it's bad that's kind of oh that's bad
is it painful yeah yeah they're painful
very painful when i when i wake up in
the morning it's swollen so like you
know i can't see and there's no
unclogging there's no like i tried i'm
doing hot compress as i'm squeezing as
hard as i can my kids are very scared
i threatened to turn it inside out the
lid and then poke it with a lamp
well but there's nothing to stab it's
just swell
you can't see yourself
you have one too right now yes buddy
yeah
the plants are great the plants are
responding nicely to are you guys gonna
give us i don't want they're not
contagious it's not
it's not stay the [ __ ] away from my sky
it's not conjunctivitis
she said it was not true
i don't really know
if there's anything we've learned as a
society it's that we we don't really
want to be listening to these dumb ass
doctors all the time right just because
some smart ass doctors trying to tell
you what to do with your health they
don't really know you don't always need
to listen use your comments
stupid science [ __ ]
the only thing that caitlin is spreading
is joy on this podcast for being here
thank you for joining us again
we're not as drunk as the last time in
the shoes
that's for the best that's probably the
best yeah maybe i'll make sense
okay
um but yeah we're here today to watch um
mac and dennis man hunters
first episode of season four uh
yeah before we watch it any memories of
uh
i don't remember
a thing
you know memories of the past yes
what year was that
this one i remember this one i remember
very distinctly we shot because we shot
a lot of it on the streets of
philadelphia yep i remember that as well
i remember writing as well like not me
writing it but i remember uh
the process the writing process um
jordan uh
i don't remember people's names
jordan and elijah jordan elijah right
the writing team jordan elijah yeah yeah
they that's right that was this was
their idea i think it was their idea
right here that they pitched us and we
were riding in a warehouse
yep in culver city oh
that's right i remember that maybe one
of our worst writers offices we ever had
yes
uh buildings and it was across the
street from where we filmed yes so i do
remember things yes
it's the year we got married was that
the year you got married here we we
we made it official
yep that was late in the year it was
september of that year september 2008
after we filmed the season you guys had
the wedding oh yeah first i broke my
back in july and then we um
got married in september oh how's your
book in 2008 what's good my foot's great
guys i did uh just a few months before
the wedding i wasn't sure if i was going
to be able to walk down the aisle oh
yeah yeah that's right i figured it out
you know yeah we got you down yeah we
got it
done
you're wearing like a regular backpack
in malibu right so like like out of like
a winery that's not easy terrain
and you know say what yeah that was a
fun wedding i remember the dance floor
was poppin
the dance floor was popping off that
night
and everybody had a real good time now
did we go from the venue to another
venue to dance or no it was right out
there it was all right out there it was
all there there it was all there right
now it's all there in the junk field
we transitioned from a lacrosse field to
a basketball court
i was just thinking of just like dust
well that's because we come from that
yeah right like you come from the dust
i'm picturing like cows feel divorced
like i have to blow my nose there's
going to be brown yeah it's going to be
brown yeah that's it it was it was a
very rare field of being being at a keg
party in uh in montgomery alabama you
know where you
boy those were back in the day when you
didn't have a phone and you had to get
directions it was like literally like
look for this [ __ ] sign look for this
there you'll see a gate you'll see a
fence
and then like two dirt roads past that
you turn right and somebody's truck will
be there yeah yeah yeah you'll see yeah
yeah and somehow you made it
every time you figured it out yeah every
time you kind of gave it up like well we
just can't find it your parents couldn't
check on you there was no i'll be home
at whatever time i'm home or i'm or i
won't i don't know oh man
it's like a treasure hunt you know it
was like a like thank god that's done
yeah that's the one improvement i think
the gps thing's been great oh right and
a person who likes to know where they're
going yeah
the social communication aspect of it i
don't think has been so good but the
gps and gps yeah yeah yeah not bad every
time i think about giving up my
smartphone i'm like there's a couple
things on there my calendar my gps you
know music my to-do list app that i like
i'll tell you guys about that later
you don't want to dive into that really
like [ __ ] organize my day all right
let's watch this watch
you
about your guys
yeah that's that's what's up all right
great well we're going to watch this
episode which i have to say has one of
my favorite d and charlie story lines in
it yes oh and you guys are the best
pairing so yeah that's true
that's true
and at any point that you want me to
stop just say stop it
that was that's
so perfect like their chemistry was like
yeah crackling right you're all
inspiring the whole thing you know
i did that intentionally though
it was a
are you excited to watch this episode
yes how are you yeah yeah
i like our show i do too usually this is
one of the ones where i feel like you're
not sure about this one i don't know
it's quite so broad with the eating of
people oh this is fun right right let's
see
your story meg is totally right your
storyline yours and caitlyn's it's you
guys are on fire in this one now okay
and i just my favorite moment one of my
favorite moments of yours in general and
on the show in general is in this
episode and it's you eating that [ __ ]
subway sandwich like a bird
like you're pecking at it like a chicken
and it is the funniest one of the
funniest things yes it's so funny that
thing can work
that hurt my neck
i bet
here we go this piece as more savory or
succulent well it's definitely way too
overcooked to be succulent but it's
still really delicious it's still savory
right now what if we soaked it in beer
do you think that would help it like
regain its succulents like a beer
that's actually really smart matt grab
us some beers bite my bird
you would never say that right steak
fry's got this like butterfly bird
delicious meats that i've been stealing
you guys of this someone who sweats as
much as you should not work with food
charlie
you son of a [ __ ]
i told you stay away from my meat spin
it out come on spin it
out now
[Laughter]
hey
i killed a deer i should get to eat it
that's the natural oil you shot a deer
that's right 10-point buck
right between soulful little eyes
always i'm a great hunter how does
hunting a defenseless creature make you
a good hunter yeah you should go after
something that could at least defend
itself you know a really great hunter
would go after something that could hunt
him back oh like a man oh hell yeah dude
a man don't even joke about no man was
joking i'm not joking i think that
hunting a man would be the only true
test of a good hunter yeah i was hunted
once i just came back from nam i was
hitching through oregon
i had a whole army of cops chasing me
through the woods
take them all out
that's rambo dude
[Laughter]
what
you just described the plot of rambo
yeah that's the first from the first
person
rambo that's not the first time you've
described your life in the way of john
ramble
[Music]
that's a terrible uh adr
i think i say [ __ ] you you you do i'm
clearly saying oh you did say yeah
[ __ ] you
every once while in those early seasons
we would throw one in there just to make
it funny for ourselves and i was
distracted by your sideburns i was going
to say do you guys want to talk about
that
pretty good wow
you won't know
you look like you were spending a lot of
time on your hair we had a lot of
different hair makeup people like they
would switch out you know you're gonna
blame this on the leo was on now no i
never let anyone touch my sideburns are
the same length as cleanse it's just
that i
but because there's a hard edge yeah
yeah yeah
so we were both going for a sidebar yeah
but did your sideburns look like that at
our wedding i don't think i was intended
i certainly hope not i was not intending
i don't i think this was a mistake on my
part
i don't think i don't think it was i
think it was one of those things where i
didn't realize that what i'd done yeah
okay i think he was in yeah you probably
looked good back then
that was the 2008 thing yeah now it
would be just like no side burnside just
cut all the way up
just [ __ ] with a mullet in the back
super hit super hip try that one
get a little bit of the sauce i don't
have any sauce left let's just do
natural juices too you're going over to
this apartment to eat meat
i like that we set up a flower in a vase
just to yeah yeah we've got a little
atmosphere you love the meat so
so much you're going to go over to his
apartment yes eat it okay that's right
going over to the apartment and and
discussing different ways to but also
it's friends right like so oh it's at
that apartment okay so yeah yeah you
explained that he's he's put a lock on
his yeah on his freezers though
looks like you two have been enjoying my
meat yes we have been you fascist meat
hog yeah
that is from like some commercial from
my childhood it was like a commercial
for like
that like the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints or something i
remember you saying that a lot i'm
singing that a lot a local commercial
and then uh and you and your friends
like stole it right we would use it and
my poor buddy uh
my buddy chris pettit had this kid
brother andrew pettit um who was like
nine years younger and
i think it was used a lot at poor
andrew's uh uh expensive expense yeah or
just take something of his and
of course andrew's now a uh like well
you would drill sergeant in the marines
and could kick the [ __ ] out of it
is that why he's a gentleman very sweet
guy but he does very good that's a good
bit though uh uh just taking something
from someone and singing sharing it's a
really cool it's so sweet thank you
seriously you can take what you want and
it ends yeah that's just permission it's
just done
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
your teeth have just torn apart your
taste buds have savored
that
was human meat
that wasn't here
[Laughter]
it took me all day but i finally
finished the list of 10 people that
would be perfect to hunt great and i
totally respect your opinion but i've
already made a decision
[Music]
be fun yeah what do you suppose is gonna
happen when we do catch them i suppose
we do something teabag related
so then oh
what we've set up that we used to tea
bags yeah yeah yeah yeah but in the
first episode weren't you saying was it
that you couldn't describe what that's
keybagging so we did balls to the chin
so
but by this point
by this point
and so we
we're making them more money so go ahead
say whatever
it's funny to re-watch these things that
you go in thinking like i don't know
about this one and then you watch me
like oh i'm thoroughly enjoying it this
was the first episode that we ever
watched with a
very large audience cause we watched it
we played this at comic-con damon
lindelof oh my god oh yeah he moderated
our panel sorry a comedic convention
yes thank you yes
so there's a comedic convention down in
san diego around the same time of the
comic
oh you weren't oh you weren't joking i
wasn't joking no no you thought it was a
comedic convention um it would be com
calm it was just a convention right
now mine were called comic because
comedic books
oh then you're right
and funny papers in my mind they were
funny papers
that's interesting
is that correct is that what a comic
book is
it's a comic it's comedic i think the
definition has expanded but it may have
started that makes that doesn't make
sense this conversation is going to
annoy a lot of people oh yeah who's
laughing
around are coming with people
opinionated
well the point is we were down at
comic-con and um
we weren't sure if we were going to fill
a room oh really we're very nervous
and then they well they they they wanted
to put us in time it was the sixth house
we requested they make the room smaller
no it was they they told us they were
putting us in in the i think it was the
largest or if not the largest one of the
largest it's like a six thousand seat
convention hall and we were like this is
going to be a disaster it's gonna be an
embarrassment like 500 people are going
to show up and it's going to look empty
and it's going to be embarrassing that
they're going to figure out a way to
like make the room there was no social
media so we have no idea who's watching
we have no feelings they're lying about
the ratings so we don't know who's
watching the show we haven't done the
night man cometh live yet we've never
been to comics the first year we've been
to columbia only made each other laugh
yes no one else we had no [ __ ] idea
of anybody and then
6 000 people showed up yes and they and
they could there were people out the
door lined about the door people
standing they were over the course yeah
remember that i don't remember that this
was the episode but i remember that and
i remember being like whoa i didn't
realize anyone was watching our show
yeah it was the first time we fully
concretely saw that people were finally
responding to the show and and like and
enjoying it that was very cool
hey frankie
sharing it's a rule now
i feel like i know you guys so well
after working together for over 15 years
and being friends for closer to 20 but i
don't know what your morning routines
are oh i don't know that i really have a
routine you know i get up i i see my kid
off to school i guess i shower i yeah up
at five stretches 505 gym 5 15 maybe a
meditation afterwards maybe not depends
if i want gratitude mm-hmm in my life
okay all right
well listen i i i know all about those
that's not what i'm talking about i'm
talking about your morning hydration
habits oh yeah yeah okay liquid iv of
course i mean look it's it's obvious
that everyone should be doing liquid iv
i mean it hydrates you twice as fast as
water it contains five essential
vitamins and has three times the
electrolytes of a traditional sports
drink so how about that yeah i like the
concord grape
uh i use it before i work out it's it's
uh subtle and not too sweet so that's
why i myself
interestingly enough i like pina colada
i like all liquid iv i like that it's
designed to enhance rapid absorption of
water and other key ingredients into the
bloodstream you know with its cellular
transport technology and i really like
that for every purchase they donate a
serving to someone in need so go ahead
and grab your liquid iv in bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidity.com
and use the code sunny at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you shop better hydration today using
promo code sunny at liquidive.com
[Music]
yeah baby this hunt is going to be so
awesome this is what it must be like
before you go into battle oh my god i
know man i'm so excited to feel my nips
holy smokes
[Laughter]
if you can work them up a little bit we
were planting the seeds of where we're
going with your character we're all
i think we're also identifying what um
what i appreciate most about when we're
approaching a scene or even just a
comedic beat that we're not always just
going for the most profane or like
offensive it's the most unexpected and i
love the idea of
frank walking in asking us what we're
doing and instead of pretending like oh
yeah you weren't just getting that's
right you lean all the way into it yeah
yeah very uh feeling
that's the unexpected joke the joke that
is that would normally happen is we'd be
like nothing we're not doing anything
nothing or that or that dennis would
want him to stop at a certain point
i'm so excited my nipples are so hard
i'm so excited at how hard they are and
my friend is going to town on the thing
that i'm excited about yeah you just
want to keep that going why would you
stop
enjoying how hard they are to make him
feel good but he also wants to bring
frank in on the action yeah right i just
want to let you know that there are
nipples this hard in this room you're
not going to yeah this is you might want
to jump in there yeah
all right this is not right i still have
the craving
i haven't even worsened before i did oh
there were five yeah so i really wanted
to ask about this were those fl did you
bring them in or they were just there i
think so yeah
wrangler well were we still at the
examiner here um or is this on no we're
on stage this is on stage
we definitely brought flies in what i
don't remember bringing flies in we had
a fly guy i doubt i think that's the
joke that the meat fly right the flies
are around the meat it must be because
they're they're all over the same place
maybe we had a fly wrangler
you know fly guy much different keep
going let's see if the flies keep
playing a role
that's either a real flyer we put it in
post or something but no because we're
putting in the sounds of it that stupid
i don't know oh i'm sorry dee well then
i guess jaws poor is stupid okay
or whatever it is you're trying to say i
think we need to find out
you understand me
i think we need to try a piece of human
flesh
i like that jaws forward joke yeah yeah
at jaws but i guess josh is stupid
and then sprinkle it with shaved pubes
no i don't like it
what what's not to like crank it with a
facebook page hilarious where were we
supposed to get that many pubes man
you can't grow them back once you laser
them off yeah now the laser makes it go
away forever kills the following is that
right yeah
that's right so you guys have to
remember that if we ever do any full
frontal
dentist stuff just wax it smooth it's a
turtle shot yeah well i don't think that
can't be a problem we can't forget
never forget
him
[Music]
good question
the hot plate is because our friend was
a
he was a chef
alone oh yeah yeah
okay you've got the wrong wow
[Laughter]
i think that was that guy's improv
i think a lot of this was improvised
yeah yeah he was he was good
i don't think i can eat this guy oh i
don't think i can right
i don't know oh boy
oh because he's black though right okay
no
no i just don't think so no you're not
sure
right it's because he's dead
that's why i'm good good
now i got a question for you
[Music]
is it racist if we don't eat this guy
[ __ ] charlie now it is
just the white guy over here looks
better than me for some reason doesn't
he
know what it is i i generally i don't
eat dark meat no i prefer the white meat
i always have yeah so it's not that
[Laughter]
getting caught up about feeling racist
when you're about to eat a human in
washington
we're just here to eat some dude he lost
me with washington but the rest i agree
with so let's see the piece of this
white guy let's get him let's get them
[Music]
that's that's amazing that's a great
scene i i thought i was going to be
uncomfortable and i end up being very
proud of that that's amazing that shit's
funny
i do not like the dark made of like a
turkey oh see i'm a big fan of the dark
brown yeah that was that was good acting
on my part on a turtle i love a dark
meat
yeah okay
moisture juice oh yeah yeah
a street rack
i'm here to help you turn the tables on
mac and dennis what do you mean they
drew first blood not you
anyway they drew first bloody
[Music]
[Laughter]
we're coming off of season three and we
have i remember having the conversation
of saying okay we tried something we got
a little broad yeah maybe we want to
reel it back in a little bit and this is
what we do because i mean arguably ten
times broader than anything we've done
we got a line reading from danny though
i think this was the last thing we shot
this season i was just going to say that
i think that's just going to say that
i think you're right i think you're
absolutely right because i remember it
was super late yep and it was like okay
we're done just let's just get through
this let's get to this and let's go
party yeah yeah let's go drink our
[ __ ] faces off
holy [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
yes bro you got to admit that is so much
more awesome than t value oh yeah take a
look at your mouth you tell me
[Laughter]
they're in their 30s
at this point right wow it'll be 30 31.
uh yeah yeah no older than that early
30s early 30s oh i was we got married i
was 31.
yeah it would have been nice if we
played a little enjoyment about you
having a blue tongue
there was a little hint to that we
didn't know where we were going we
didn't know actually yeah yeah
we knew we knew we knew oh yeah sure
yeah it was a salt he he wants to have
his balls in his mouth with consent yeah
he wants to be awake he doesn't want him
to miss the whole thing
we need to set a trap
yeah
and how do you catch a crank
like a giant bird
here we go here we go there it is
i'm sorry we have to talk about that
it's amazing it's amazing and the sound
of the paper yeah
i think we may have enhanced we enhanced
that big time yeah i just remember
i just remember it
it started hurting so bad because my
neck was like definitely starting to
hurt but i was like no no this is so it
feels so funny just keep going
you'd call it out immediately after
you're eating that burrito like some
sort of giant bird
yeah i was just watching that i've been
like did we feel like we had to do that
so we knew
you were in case people were confused
about what i was doing no no no
like to be like that's who glenn was
talking about no right yes no that that
that well yeah i mean that is what we're
talking about we're going to trap
cricket with the bird i know but so do i
repeat the line so that's a clown did we
feel like i'll be honest with the
audience
i think you didn't believe in me that's
what i think
i doubt that
[Music]
we gotta do more hallway scenes yeah
dude these are not coming off seriously
oh no they're not going to i used to ask
you that's going to be your look for a
while i think that's my mom
i knew she showed up at one point and i
was just looking at that yeah yeah so i
think but all of our parents are street
urchins yeah right exactly
tom and mary day they have not appeared
in streets not yet no the olsens haven't
either yeah there's still time they were
just there visiting when we were
shooting this and uh we just tossed her
in there and you're dead but i was in
the previous yeah yeah my dad has not
been on the show
but yes uh that's my mom everyone
if you're watching the episode the
homeless lady passed out
do you explain to her like we're coming
off the scene where people are trying to
choose like human meat that they're
eating and then we're coming back i
don't know if i don't know how much of
it is
like charlie we're in charlie's
apartment building and there's always
you know
people
passed out
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is that jealous for jesus
yes is that jealous for jesus wow
now i'm jealous of jesus and all that
he's done
how can i compare to god's
yeah that's jealous for jesus which was
okay so the library music right like
okay so yes uh so that the first time
that song that we decided to put i guess
in as your phone ring uh we heard that
when in the abortion episode in season
one
was it when when you were in the car
actually banging the girl yeah yeah yeah
yeah jealous for jesus is playing yeah
and it was again it was just a library
song just like a cheap song and this was
an of an era this dictates us we're
ringtones worth all the races yes yeah
and everybody take a piece
yeah yeah yeah so we thought we thought
it'd be funny to carry that through and
absolutely state of the art yeah yeah
let's definitely study the art
prepare to be burned alive
this is the point where i would normally
burn
i just did it to prove a point i think i
made
[Music]
please
[Laughter]
i told you it was people because i
wanted to freak you out because you're
stealing my food no no no no no why am i
always hungry
you probably got a tapeworm see that's
what grounds it to me because that's
right that's right no that is that's
that's more grounded than i remembered
which is that we never actually get it
and that yeah we just we don't need them
that's what we want yeah but you're so
hungry all the time you don't know where
the hunger is coming from and that's why
you start to act like crazy and you
can't sleep and stuff yeah that's that's
why you're ill yeah yeah
okay are we done here because we are
bored of [ __ ] no no no no no not yet
oh yeah get ready i love that he thinks
he's got us full of strawberry blonde
hair
balls
frank grab them
we're not doing that
i lied what what what is it with you
people i mean you guys are always
touching each other's nipples putting
your balls in each other's mouth this is
real yes this is this is real this is
real this is daddy's coming us and being
like
your generation and your idea of what's
funny what is this
nipples
i would i i would occasionally every
once in a while just like go and like
just touch
danny's nipples just to see how he and
he hated it he [ __ ] hated it but then
eventually he realized it was that i was
getting too much satisfaction and so he
had to let you so he had to start yeah
what to do what to do yes it's just us
it's just you and us and a
couple pairs of sour
sway balls
[Music]
i mean we were 30. i mean
this is not a bunch of kids getting
together no yeah it's not exactly we
like it we like to look back on this and
go you know we were kids we were kids we
were kids doing this now no
we were creatively young you know like
yeah entertainment
[Music]
i'm getting pretty burned out i noticed
that you know what i mean well you know
what it's i'm giving my all doing these
ads week in and week out and i feel like
it's time for a vacation didn't you just
get back from a vacation that's right i
just got back from vacation rob and i
need another one i could use a vacation
too and of course glenn's literally on
vacation right now oh uh yes yes uh
sorry having a little bit of trouble
following you guys i just got back from
the beach and um a couple margaritas
well clearly it's peak vacation season
and today we salute all of those who
make a getaway truly great and memorable
sure i mean you get you got your hotel
concierge right uh who else you got the
tour guides yeah a good charismatic
bartender is always fun well you know
outstanding talent is crucial for a
successful business and when you're
hiring if you are hiring you can find
talent for roles like these and more at
zip recruiter try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
sunny that's right zip recorder uses its
powerful technology to find and match
you with the right candidates for your
job let the machines do the work for you
people yeah you can even invite your top
choices to apply to your job i mean boom
work smarter okay not harder
get that hiring done and you two can be
sipping margs at the beach in the middle
of a weekday like this guy travel to
this easy to remember web destination
ziprecruiter.com
sunny that's where you can try zip
recruiter for free again that is
ziprecruiter.com
s u n n y sunny zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire
[Music]
kaitlyn yeah what other things do you
want to compliment about me in that
episode or really any
any of the episodes
maybe we'll save something like your
first appearance on the podcast but it's
been a while and i've done a lot of
episodes
you feel like there's room
yeah you have done a lot of episodes i
think maybe you should
[Laughter]
hang on i'd like to know what's the
worst thing they've ever made you do on
the show
the worst things are the best things
though we've a we've never made you do
anything let's just be no
100 consent
i've consented to all of it that's good
um nothing inappropriate
except
sleeping with and marrying my boss
that's about it the bog thing was really
uh painful yeah that
why don't you just because we don't know
if uh you know you're gonna be with us
when we cover that episode and boys
that's gonna be what's a long time it's
a long time from now so why don't you
guys
be able to keep this up for that long
right like there's i don't know the
people keep listening guys i was just in
new york city and i ca i i meant to text
you and then i was like there's no if i
keep texting them they won't believe me
how often i was walking around and
someone would walk right up to me with
earbuds and say that they were listening
to me as they were right yeah including
one guy who was downtown who was walking
and looking at his phone and like looked
up and then just turned and put it here
he was looking watching the podcast
walking down the street in new york city
you should look up that's dangerous that
is dangerous
a lot of scaffolding still building it
they haven't finished it yet they're
close are they they're close every time
i go to new york i'm like you guys
you're almost finished
it's just [ __ ] construction yeah
we're always [ __ ] finished over here
relax
thank goodness
gonna be this [ __ ] noise
[ __ ] city all right don't be so
impatient
you know what i would love to do
are you getting uncomfortable with
accidents
i just had to put my armpits together
just in case because
and yet you became an actor yeah i don't
know by the way if i just overhear it
it's usually okay it's when someone's
like doing it to me i feel like oh god
i'm supposed to pretend oh yeah that i
understand that i get that i get yeah
but that was not that was us doing a bit
but i'm here and i feel very much the
focus of the attention right now you
know we should chime in i think i should
dig deeper on that i think there's more
underneath there this should all be
something underneath that i only have
limited time here guys this should all
be to me
well speaking of that i feel like um one
thing you you've been you've been doing
a lot of tv
and you haven't you haven't done a lot
of films you haven't done a lot of the
films that you were interested i know
you're a big stephen spielberg fan we
haven't heard from stephen in a while um
he does check yes steven steven comes in
from time to time he calls
he shows up every once in a while and he
doesn't like to be on camera but he but
he does every once in a while he'll pop
by and and uh do you want to see if we
can get him on the phone and maybe he
can talk to caitlin just about like what
we'll see if he's got any questions yeah
if he's got any and if you maybe have
any questions for him i think that's a
good idea
so i just you guys have stephen spudella
on your old friends is so busy
yeah
hello
oh hi stephen we have uh
caitlin on the podcast today
this is max again how you doing over
there oh i'm good we've got caitlin in
the studio and we were just wondering
caitlyn olsen yes katelyn olsen the one
and only
my god are you kidding me caitlyn olsen
that is she's in the studio right now
with you guys
are the guys here they are hey guys
hey what's up steven how are you doing
i'm stevie
buddy uh it's good it's good hey listen
just uh you know cranking away over here
i got uh
producing
what is it
john how many movies we producing right
now
47. you know what
hello mr spielberg hi is this caitlin
yeah is this really you yeah yeah yeah
they're usually on no no they never let
me on but they did this time and i can't
believe my luck um hi how are you i'm
doing very well oh my god so i'm i'm
nervous i i i don't watch you i don't
get nervous around a lot of people but i
do get nervous at the thought of talking
to you
i have tried to get you in so many of my
movies and you just never failed i i i
haven't heard a thing about this this is
the first time hearing of this oh well
who are you going i can say this
sometimes we will get
calls checking a veil what while we're
well well we never really know when
we're going to shoot the season so we
try to just say you're not available all
year round it's not fair you guys are
always working uh i know yes because we
don't know when we're right yes we're
going to work so you say i'm not
available well yes
to steven spielberg yeah well he's got
other options you guys suck i do have
other options but i gotta say a very
talented young lady and i would love to
get you one of my movies at some point
but uh you know i gotta say it really
hurts the number of times you said no to
me i didn't i didn't charlie did you
hear him he just said that he's they're
the ones that are saying no i didn't say
no i would say i would say yes if you
wanted to ask again
i would move things around okay
speaking of moving things around so uh
west side story i saw the musical what
was the thinking about changing the
order of like the the songs
i i'm not you know i have not seen the
final cut of that
so i'm not totally sure what you're
talking about
i never did huh i've got about 47 movies
in uh various stages of production right
now that makes sense and watch them all
that makes sense all right
can't watch them all all right listen
speaking of guys i really gotta run wait
uh sorry so uh what about rob and glenn
you got anything for them and any stuff
you're doing you know yeah any
opportunities like
no thank you so much thank you so much
god damn it sorry bye mr milk thank you
great caitlyn uh always a pleasure thank
you so much caitlyn for having me in
your studio megan you did a wonderful
job yes
thank you and mara and team and mara and
yes that's true that was very rude of me
you can come back literally any time is
that true
yes
is that
let's not bring your little eye friend
next time
[Laughter]
i can't guarantee that this guy doesn't
seem to be going might be here to stay
it's us from now on
our package deal
get steal now okay well you heard of a
two-hander anytime you hire me
what it's the new comedy duo
yeah i'll make him funny don't worry
olson and stein
[Music]